et maintenant j'aime bien faire des
immersion et ça c'est plus cool et ça je
vous avez de la lumière sur votre cas
points réguliers avec vous pour voir un
c'est absurde communauté ce que moi je
pas mal de vidéos si vous pouvez
clair mais mille et une façons de parler
voyez c'est un peu c'est quand même un
pense à plus intéressant parce que
c'est vraiment la sécurité pour les
regarder il y en a une je vous ai
peu ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est
pourrais pas y être tout le temps est ce
combien de vue sur cette vidéo 11000
vivant puis c'est pas toujours même
tech donc voilà c'est toutes ces
peu plus bas et si je vais regarder sur
que ça vous botte ses deux premiers
motards éviter de se planter en vous
présenté le combi 100% électrique de
passé ce qu'il réussisse qui a pas
questions que je me pose et dont je
décor pas toujours les mêmes plans et ça
points après il ya un deuxième point qui
voyez la signalisation ça va s'allumer
réussi ou est-ce qu'on en ait un instant
l'audi q4 itron là les scores sont pas
volkswagen c'est un nouveau complice et
voulais parler avec vous aujourd'hui
râlent pas super intéressant et j'ai
change et ça je trouve ça chouette je
par rapport que vous allez mettre un
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
tu es je dis bien un instant t parce que
à l'oeil du buzz on n'était pas due au
sais pas si vous avez vu cette vidéo
fait des live un peu sur youtube
clignotant ton à droite à gauche vous
dingue et là je crois qu'on est en
choc du côté de bmw linkem coloriage
commentaire on se retrouve très vite
une chaîne ça évolue il peut se passer
d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas vu allait
avez un petit boîtier connecté à les
derrière c'est pour les 500 milles
avoir sur ma chaîne elle est très
parce que j'ai plein de trucs derrière
dessous des dix mille
plein de choses et il se passe plein de
abonnés d'ailleurs merci à vous d'être
récente et fo mais le lien en
schumi c'est de la fraude c'est un peu
brancher directement à votre bécane on
9988 presque 6000 et voyagent donc je me
choses mais pour autant si vous revenez
donc je souhaite vous parler plein de
descriptions je trouvais ça intéressant
aussi nombreuses et si nombreux c'est
vous avait pas un option vous avez de la
est ce que ce type de format là ça vous
surtout which aussi un certain moment je
produits et s'écoulent et il va se
en arrière et si vous vous souvenez
commande vocale notamment alex a vous
suis dit tiens est ce qu'en fait
l'impression des fois ya des sujets qui
c'est un mois de septembre dernier
plaît moi je me sens vraiment cool
passer plein de choses pour ça c'est une
l'automobile c'est un sujet qui vous
suis parvenu parce que j'ai pas trouvé
allez avoir le train qui les ont votre
vous intéressent plus que d'autres si je
bonne nouvelle pour les soins de vous
j'avais fait une vidéo un peu de
honnêtement alors ça sera pas toujours
bon format et puis c'est en discutant le
votre famille vos amis amusez-vous
intéresse que c'est un truc qui vous
regarde par exemple je sais pas moi si
au bord de la mer je passe pas ma vie à
changements de choses qui devait un peu
parcours votre vidal bref c'est
passionne et peut-être mais peut-être
jour avec or oriane qui émaillent
vachement bien ces signes et alice est
se passer je vous disais c'est un
la plage je vous rassure mais c'est pas
la x combien ce qu'on a eue de vue
profiter le printemps arrive c'est cool
channel manager sur youtube coucou
pas chez moi et si vous regardez des
une innovation française pour l'instant
constat je m'ennuie pas si vous êtes
ça peut être dans paris ça peut être
sujets d'automobiles dit le mans
oriane et qui m'a dit pourquoi tu ferais
et j'espère que bientôt la fin de la
c'est trop tôt on les voit se sentira
là-dessus sur la x vous avez des 23
dans ce cas même en tout cas moi je
commentaire est ce que vous aimez tous
leur voyage à une époque je voyageais
bientôt sans marcher parce que sans ça
m'ennuie le coc but d'accélérer un peu
pas un truc qui s'appellerait savez greu
pandémie et qu'on puisse à tout sauf un
beaucoup alors bien évidemment s'en
les gens rentrent vraiment dans le côté
l'échéance fait beaucoup de vidéo sur
vraiment cool ils vont faire un petit
et je trouve l'idéal est dingue est cool
textes c'est l'idéal pour moi c'est vous
doutera avec le co vide des voyages y en
milles la garde et la i 4 il ya eu
des gros qu'un des gros et ça c'est cool
starter à l'indigo bientôt donc si vous
des smartphones des tonnes des tonnes de
et maisons basses bisous sa vie
présentez l'automobile mais au travers
en fait l'idée de ses lives ça serait de
a moins des voyages de presse m à moins
smartphones et puis beaucoup de tournage
êtes un plaisir à papa part ça ça a
du prisme l'attaqué est ce que c'est
de présentation on a moins il y en a eu
ne pas de faire le sav des marques mais
cartonné purement parce que je pense
en studio parce que plus de déplacements
vous intéresse c'est ce que voudrait que
en début d'année je vous emmener au csa
professionnels ce qui fait que c'est
qu'il ya la vraie communauté monarque
un peu c'est à dire être là pour vous
le fasse différemment est ce que
las vegas vous emmener également à
toujours le même des cordes toujours la
l'automobile ici sur cette chaîne
s'intéressait est ce qu'il ya des sujets
guider vous aider essayer de trouver des
même chose qui se passe c'est un fait
barcelone au mwc et puis on aura
comme ça donc je vous parle qui sont un
quelque chose qui vous intéressent à
solutions ensemble on pourrait le faire
souder pas mal de questions donc dites
les choses sont toujours un peu les
peu différent sur les autres réseaux
d'autres là dans quelques temps je dois
sur youtube on pourrait faire aussi sur
mêmes et c'est ce que je vous disais
moi ce que vous en pensez en commentaire
partir normalement à milan ça se fait et
sociaux voilà ça c'est pareil c'est des
d'ailleurs dans cette vidéo c'est à dire
que je teste beaucoup de smartphones et
à la semaine prochaine je vais tester un
réflexions j'ai je poste pas mal de
twitch peut-être une semaine sur deux je
ça peut être aussi l'occasion de vous
nouveau venu tout cas autant savoir si
c'est super mais il ya un moment les
choses mais des fois j'ai l'impression
montrer des trucs un peu différemment
sais pas tu es pas toujours à la même
produits se ressemblent énormément et il
qu'il ya des doublons qui se font un
ça vous intéresse ou pas c'est vraiment
date parce que c'est compliqué par
donc ça c'est un peu sur la forme et sur
n'y a pas de grande nouveauté il n'y a
cube et que ça vous botte pas que ça
rapport à mon non pas du tout on est
le fond il ya cette idée de smartphones
le premier sujet et puis deuxième truc
pas de grande stimulation est un produit
toujours dispo à la même date voyez le 3
vous intéresse pas donc qu'est ce que
c'est je vous avais dit je voulais faire
je parle beaucoup de smartphones c'est
vous voudrez venir voir là dessus est ce
heures le jeudi soir par exemple j'ai
évoluer les choses alors c'est vrai que
en appelle un autre et les produits se
une chaîne de tête et je me dis tiens à
que vous avez une idée ou pas si vous
essayé mais je m'en sors pas donc il
ressemblent même si certains racontent
il ya des choses qu'on parle énormément
ce que je vais pas essayer de vous
n'avez pas d'idée ou plus totalement
faut trouver d'autres trucs est ce que
parler de choses un peu différemment
évolué parce que je voulais le faire
ça vous botte et est ce que vous avez
des histoires un peu différente même si
comprendre et puis c'est à moi de vous
vous présenter d'autres trucs alors il
proposer du contenu c'est pas à vous
envie parce que je suis sur des
évoluer plus vite parce que j'ai un
certains mettre l'accent sur un double
ya effectivement des smartphones il ya
lever des fonds mais a contrario si vous
événements et qu'un truc un petit peu
flash led à l'avant même si certains
nouveau studio et que je voulais
chaud et bien que l'on se fasse un petit
tout ce qui découle du smartphone c'est
avez des choses qui vous plaisent une
peuvent changer de couleur dans le dos
vraiment appuyer dessus pour aller un
live sur twitter ou sur youtube dites le
à dire bien les astuces pour bien venir
paille vous avez envie de voir certains
même si certains se cachent les choses
peu plus loin et ça a pris un ton
endroits et pas d'autres c'est aussi
les utiliser mais est-ce qu'on n'irait
un peu différentes mais l'histoire reste
bilingue et je suis en train de le
moi et qui d'ailleurs quelle plateforme
cool d'avoir votre ressenti là dessus on
pas ces sites se trouvaient d'autres
finaliser ça aurait dû être fait il ya
vous préféreriez dans ce cas là l'une ou
toujours un peu la même parce que de
fait avancer les choses ensemble je vous
choses d'autres produits d'autre qu'un
des mois mais ce n'est pas le cas donc
toute façon on parle de smartphones et
l'autre dit le mans aux commentaires
propose du contenu et vous vous le dites
c'est comme ça ça a évolué on est
peu rigolo qui serait un peu différent
même si on va changer des choses un
donc ça ce trouve ça cool et puis
ce que vous en pensez si vous aimez ou
ensuite c'est se poser la question
petit peu hardware même un peu software
alors je les fais ici avec les ray-ban
quasiment à la fin d'une v1 du studio
pas être quelle manière on va penser
également d autres réseaux je suis
ça reste un smartphone par moments j'ai
facebook parce qu on est venu me le
voilà peu pour l'aider alors moi j'ai
propre à pouvoir avancer et travailler
mon idée très perso de comment je dois
proposait je trouve l'idée super
l'impression de tourner un peu rond donc
présent sur tik tok sur instagram je
là dessus vous raconter les choses un
intéressante mais ce que vous vous
je me suis dit je vais essayer de jouer
faire et deux audois allaient machel
petit peu différemment donc ça c'est
je vous en ai notamment sur la route
grattez des produits des idées si
fais beaucoup de villes sans sur
mais je pense que c'est important vous
cool et je suis content mais ça a pris
instagram un peu story mais pas trop
essayé différents trucs on est partis
voyez d'être capable de s'arrêter et de
d'aller chercher autre chose que je
du temps et variées autant d'autres
surtout des virils ce sera facebook
tester un peu voir ce qui se passait du
pourrais vous présenter sur la chaîne je
faire ce break et parle avec vous alors
moments où je vous en ai parlé c'était
notamment en vidéo avec bassement ce que
pense se prête aussi un sujet super
le 2 septembre l'action de cette vidéo
côté de l'automobile oui et là j'ai fait
je m'arrête pas dans ma du tournage du
intéressant et que ça peut nous emmener
on est au mois d'avril ça fait quand
plein de trucs là j'ai un peu ralenti
j'ai fait des contenus qui ont été
même quelques longs mois et je me suis
un peu sur autre chose et est ce que il
cartonné sur facebook permet à plus d'un
ces derniers jours parce que c'est les
dit waouh n'était pas exactement comme
ya des sujets que j'ai fait également
vacances et que je maximise le temps que
million 3 une vidéo c'est dingue il y en
ça que je voulais avancer et alors c'est
notamment voyez sur la fin des
a d'autres qui qui qui avancent pas trop
je peux passer en famille versus le
pas un constat d'échec parce que autant
influenceurs il n'ya pas longtemps j'ai
donc savoir si ça vous botte et quel
ce que j'ai dit ça reste d'actualité
temps que je passe à bosser parce que je
fait une vidéo peut-on de faire
type de contenu vous voudriez venir voir
s'arrête dans un coin de ma tête mais
confiance subjectivité versus
suis tout le temps en train de bosser et
autant peut-être que vous vous le
ça me permet voiliers de prendre ce
je me suis rendu compte que j'ai fait
objectivité sais pas si vous l'avez vu
ressentez comme ça parce que vous vous
moment où je vous posez ces questions et
une vidéo liée à la cartonné cet essai
dites j'en sais rien dire dites moi ce
que je trouve assez intéressant aussi
sur les secrets un peu tout ce qui se
que vous en pensez en commentaire mais
je pouvoir discuter avec vous les yeux
sur un casque chez qu'est ce que pour
il dit des choses il voulait faire
passe dans mon métier secret de youtube
dans l'objectif même si c'est derrière
deux motos en fait que j'ai vu au cv
d'autres trucs différemment et ça n'a
tout ce qui est un peu derrière je vous
pas été fait alors sans maillot de
l'écran dans vos yeux voyait ya juste
savez gas et j'ai trouvé ça génial mon
parlais un peu de burnout est ce que
questions est ce que vous aimez les
travail classe à un proto c'est super
cette barrière numérique entre nous mais
c'est un des sujets qui vous intéressent
contraintes de sujets comme ça c'est à
attention - franceschi ça fait l'italie
moyens que le côté un peu plus coulisses
sinon on est en direct et ça c'est cool
dire avec un plan on est en studio
donc dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
voir comment ça se passe vous parler un
posait phase calme avec une caméra
commentaire on en parle un jeu je
peu de beau job par rapport à la vie de
au-dessus bon là elle est posée mais
elle tourne pas tout risque ont atteint
regarde je lis je vous répondrais et cc
famille c'est pas évident je suis pas
le top shot donc est ce que cette idée
toujours chez moi et même assez peu
du fass can't stop shop ça vous
est-ce que c'est des choses qui vous
voilà c'est un sujet important donc
intéressent est ce que voulait qu'on est
intéresse quand je vous présente des
un peu dans ses coulisses là que je vous
voila moi j'ai envie d'aller vers des
produits ou est ce que a contrario vous
montre à puce qui se passe je peux le
choses un peu plus en extérieur je me
trouvez que c'est un peu rébarbatif
faire j'ai plein de trucs à vous
cache pas un peu plus longue et je me
toujours un peu la même chose et qui à
raconter là dessus mais j'ai dit que
dis que des fois c'est un peu froissé
c'était pas les choses qu allez vous
un moment on tourne un peu à moi je
intéresse et donc dites moi c'est des
présentation de produits c'est toujours
trouve que c'est un peu le truc des fois
choses qui vous intéressent voir un peu
un produit c'est factuel chessa et plus
c'est un peu trop la même chose je
comment ça se passe de ce côté là je
trouve ça un peu relou à force et c'est
vous emmener un peu dans dans le côté je
pour ça que je vous en ai sur autre
suis surpris que la note j'essaie de ne
vous prend par la main pour moi c'est
chose alors rien d'utile et trouvait
pas oublier de structure est en fait un
cool et que j'ai fait à l'exercice il ya
l'idée de façon de la chaîne c'est à
dire que votre pote qui vous présente
pur pas partir un peu de tous les côtés
quelques jours je vous ai présenté les
les produits cha regarde j'ai trouvé ce
mais voilà donc ça c'est super important
lunettes de ray ban avait fait en
nouveau truc et on ne part sur le
partenariat avec facebook c'est les
et puis il ya autre chose on a beaucoup
terrain on va regarder ce qu'on peut en
ray-ban stories et je vous ai emmenés au
faire on regarde la vérité est ce qu'on
parlé lorsque je faisais des lives tient
fait un disque ordre soit sur des scores
peut faire ou pas faire voilà donc
bord de la plage par quelques jours de
l'idée c'est ça est-ce qu'on fait que ça
qu'on puisse se retrouver en dehors des
vacances en famille et j'ai essayé de
est ce qu on ouvre un peu à d'autres
vidéos est ce que ça vous intéresse si
vous emmener dans autre chose une autre
choses en reste avec un temps c'est très
je fais un disque hors laisser oui
façon de faire pour vous présenter ses
qu'est ce que voudraient venir trouver
alors est ce que voudrait que vous
lunettes et je pense que je vous en en
donnez conseils des astuces parce que
[Musique]